there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
november to test for ourselves let's
start with the brand everyone is talking
about ariana grande's rem beauty i don't
have every product but i have a decent
batch now i love miss ponytail and i
will buy anything she tells me to but we
definitely have some products here that
are underwhelming the skips for me are
the volumizing mascara and the eyeliner
the mascara was pretty clumpy and i've
tried better mascara formulas at the
drugstore the eyeliner also wasn't great
which is shocking because i feel like
that's her thing it was just skipping on
the eye and it wasn't as intensely black
as i wanted it to be everything else i
tried i loved the lip products are very
pigmented and comfortable on the lips
the plumping gloss has this really nice
minty scent and the lipstick smells like
vanilla cake i love it also i know
everyone hated the packaging but come on
this lipstick is so cute it looks like a
little astronaut the liquid shadow was
super easy to blend and looked pretty on
the eyes i will say i wish it was more
sparkly it looked a little dull for me
if you can only get one product from
this brand though get the highlighter
topper it's more on the metallic side
but not glittery at all and it looks
amazing on the skin
i freaked out when i saw that elf came
out with basically their own version of
the abh brow freeze i still love that
fluffy laminated brow look so of course
i had to get it and compare the two
mine did come super cloudy and white
looking on the website the product looks
totally clear just like the abh brow
freeze so i don't know what that's about
anyway i applied the elf brow lift on my
right brow using the specific brow lift
applicator they released with it
and already i could tell that this is
the same as the brow freeze or at least
as close as you can get it didn't take a
lot of product to get the brow looking
full and fluffy and i also love the
applicator because it came with this
little flat piece at the end to really
press the brow hairs into place i used
the abh brow freeze on my left brow so
you can see how similar the effect is i
highly highly highly recommend this if
you're into this kind of brow look
i was so confused when i saw this petri
dish looking highlighter all over tik
tok this is the huda beauty rose quartz
face gloss highlighting do and it's
essentially a cream highlighter face
gloss hybrid i've never been interested
in these kinds of products because they
tend to remove foundation and that's
pretty much what happened with this the
formula is almost tacky it's very sticky
so everywhere i applied it it was
lifting off more and more foundation the
glow it gives is actually pretty nice
but it's not worth the trouble for me
i'd rather just use a powder highlighter
purple blush has been everywhere lately
and i've been wanting to try it so bad
this is one of the purple blushes i kept
seeing the made by mitchell blursh i'm
not saying that weird that's what it's
called i was playing with fire applying
a liquid blush over my already powdered
base a purple blush nonetheless but i
did it anyway and this formula actually
blew my mind it didn't remove any
foundation it didn't get patchy and it
was so effortless to blend out i don't
know if i'm super sold on purple blush
on my skin tone i just don't think that
it's more flattering than my normal like
peachy orange blushes but it's still
pretty i definitely want more blushes
from this brand i was so intrigued by
this concealer because it's described as
a concealer serum which i've never tried
before when i was applying it with my
brush i was getting excited because it
seemed like the coverage was great it
was super creamy but then i started
blending on the rest of my face it
blended out just fine and i thought it
looked good but something weird was
happening on my under eyes specifically
on my right side the product started to
pill up and get kind of weird but it
didn't do that on my left side so i'm
confused i think it all looked better
after i set it with powder finished my
makeup and applied my setting spray but
i'm not a huge fan of this concealer yet
maybe i just have to try it again with a
different foundation i am so not a
glitter person but i saw some videos of
this particular glitter in action and
fell in love this is the la girl glitter
holic glitter topper in hollow glam oh
my god say that five times fast it has
this color shifting magic in it that
makes it look like you have nothing on
your eyes but then you move your head
and it's like purple and then blue i
don't even know how to describe it but
i'm really obsessed it has a built-in
base so you don't need to use any
glitter adhesive just apply it with your
fingers i think i would still use this
with a glitter base just for some extra
security but i'm paranoid i love this
and it's only six bucks
[Music]
[Music]